[Applause]
the irony is very thick here tonight I
uh was listening to Alvaro earlier and
he read something from somebody saying
well Spencer he uh he has no interest in
dialogue now note that that was written
by somebody who was turning down an
invitation to have a dialogue with me
here
tonight note the irony note the irony
that the people who claim to
be the tolerant and broadminded and
multiculturalist people are fronting for
a man who is an open proponent of a the
most repressive political and societal
system in human history because the Imam
fisel Abdul Ru is an open proponent of
sharia of Islamic law and uh we have to
be perfectly honest about this that
Sharia in its entirety is absolutely
opposed to the freedom of speech
particularly non-muslims speaking about
Islam which can bring a death penalty
under Islamic law as well as denying the
freedom of conscience calling for the
death penalty for those who leave Islam
denying equality of rights to women in
numerous
ways and institutionalizing
discrimination against women and
non-muslims the Imam FAL Abdu is uh
committed to a project that gauges the
adherence to to Sharia in various
countries with the obvious objective of
increasing that
inherence and he calls in his book
what's right with Islam is what's right
with America for restrictions on the
freedom of speech and claims that the uh
United States is completely compatible
United States law is completely
compatible with Sharia and the
principles that he discusses are indeed
principles that do coincide between
American law and Islamic law but he
makes no distinctions in terms of ruling
out in any fashion whatsoever these
Draconian aspects of sharia that are
opposed to universally accepted Notions
of Human Rights it should be noted that
Charles Malik the president of Lebanon
right after World War II was involved in
the drawing up of the universal
Declaration of Human Rights at the
United Nations and he made sure
personally that article 18 would be
included in the Universal declar of
Human Rights specifying that there would
be the freedom and that governments and
in the UN should protect the freedom to
change one's religion or to have no
religion at
all and some people didn't understand
why he was so exercised about that and
why that was such an important thing to
him but this was something that he was
seeing in Lebanon in the 1940s that
people who are exercising their free
conscience were being brutalized and
sometimes even killed in the name of
Islam by
Muslims now note again the irony when I
say that to you then many of you will go
away and say Spencer is hateful and says
terrible things and hates Muslims but
actually I've never killed an
apostate I've never threatened
one all I've done is point out that it's
a bad thing to do oh how racist and
bigoted is
that no I stand with Malik I stand with
the universal Declaration of Human
Rights I stand for the Dignity of the
human person for women as well as for
men for non-muslims as well as for
Muslims and that is what this is all
about when it comes down to it the Imam
Fel Abdul whether he builds his mosque
at Ground Zero or
not is fronting for a radically
intolerant ideology and is one of its
foremost International
spokesmen and yet the people out here
think that if they are helping him out
and many of you no doubt think that if
you're standing with him then you're
standing on the side of everything
that's good and right and true against
all the racists and bigots well I'll
tell you the oppression of women is not
a race the denial of the free conscience
and the free spirit is not a
race freedom of speech is not a race and
to defend those things is not even
remotely racist and anybody who believes
that you know you really ought to be
ashamed of yourself for wasting your
parents money and coming to college when
you don't have a brain in your
head look freedom of speech freedom of
speech is the first element of any free
Society any society that is that's not a
tyranny that's not an authoritarian
system with the boot on the face and the
denial of the human
spirit
because if a tyrant can arrest somebody
for dissenting from what he is saying
and doing then obviously he can have
free
reign but if it becomes a matter of
legal
protection that what is said that
dissent can be
voiced then the tyrant's power is
drastically limited because opposition
to him can be
aired discussion can be had dialogue can
be had between him and his
opponents and the society is immensely
healthier and much Freer freedom of
speech is a fundamental bullwark against
tyranny and
authoritarianism that is an absolute
principle that is one of the reasons why
the United States of America became such
a great and powerful
country because of this kind of
freedom and yet some of the people who
have lived who have enjoyed these
freedoms who whose fathers and mothers
fought and died for these freedoms you
actually dare to stand here
tonight and to say that the freedom of
speech ought to be denied to certain
people because we don't like what they
say
well good luck to you but if that happen
if you keep doing that one day they're
going to come for you
too and you're you're going to voice
something that's not convenient to them
and they're going to get you out of
their way and you will have helped
and so you know I don't know that many
of the protesters are in here I wish you
they had all come in because I'd be
happy to discuss things but uh in point
of fact to oppose a triumphal mosque at
Ground
Zero is as Pamela Geller said it has
nothing to do with religious liberty
nobody's talking about denying Muslims
religious liberty in the United
States but look even if the Imam rou is
exactly who he claims to be
even if we leave out all the deceptive
statements about how they say over here
that it's a mosque and then they say
over here that it's not a mosque it's a
cultural center because it's got a
swimming pool have you ever heard of
those big mega churches that the
Protestant evangelicals have and they
got swimming pools and tenants courts
and racket ball and everything nobody
ever says oh it's not a church because
it's got a swimming
pool come on you're being sold to bill
of
goods in any case if we leave aside his
dishonesty and leave aside all the the
inconsistencies in the statements that
he has made and that Daisy Khan has made
and that Sharif Al Jamal has made and
all the others and we say yes it's going
to be a monument of Tolerance and peace
and Reconciliation and
Harmony how many people in the Islamic
world are going to understand that does
the Imam rouf control Communications in
the Islamic world does he have a
universal platform so that his ideas can
be universally disseminated he does not
how is it going to be understood in the
Islamic world is going to be dictated by
cultural and historical precedent and by
societal
Norms this is just common sense they're
going to look around in their own
environment and see what they what they
see in their experience and understand
it in that way perfectly reasonable
anybody would do that that's that's why
uh many of us are here tonight
protesting because you're reacting to
various stimuli in your environment
noxious as it may
be now the fact is if we count how many
triumphal mosques have been built either
converted from Hindu temples churches
and synagogues or built over the sites
of former churches Hindu temples and
synagogues how many of them thousands
literally thousands the the Hindu
historian Cedar goel has a whole book
full which is just a list of Hindu
temples destroyed and mosques put in
their place all over India
all over the Middle East and North
Africa it was synagogues and
churches triumphal mosques universally
understood as such the Dome of the Rock
was built there precisely because that's
where the Jewish temple was the AIA
Sophia was converted into a mosque
because it was the grandest church in
Christendom these things were
Declarations of the Victory and
superiority of
Islam now how many mosques of
reconciliation and Harmony built at the
site of a previous Islamic Jihad attack
are there mosques built in order to
build Bridges with the people who had
been attacked and to show a different
face of Islam how many of those are
there in the Islamic
world how many of those are there
anywhere none zero this would be the
first and so pardon me for being
respectfully skeptical if I think that
it might not be understood as being the
first but would be understood in light
of these other this Avalanche of other
historical precedents and cultural
precedents that that exist all around
the world and what does it mean so what
then why should we care if it seemed to
be a victory
mosque well this is a very simple thing
as well you may recall Osama Bin Laden
you remember him Osama Bin Laden has
recounted many things many very
interesting things about the development
of his own thought very fascinating
individual and one of the things that he
said once was that he saw you remember
the Blackhawk incident in Somalia in the
1990s when American troops were were
were treated very brutally and Bill
Clinton withdrew from Somalia as a
direct result of the Blackhawk incident
and so Osama Bin Laden was watching all
this and he has explained when he
saw that the American troops were being
withdrawn after the Blackhawk incident
then he knew we were the weak horse we
were a paper tiger we were not willing
to fight we were not willing to stand up
for ourselves we were not willing to
make any sacrifices and he knew it was
the time to step up operations and press
forward to final
Victory so we allow a huge 16 story now
actually it started out 13 and then it
went to 15 and now 60 Minutes Sharie El
Jamal revealed it would be 16 who knows
it could be 25 or 30 or 100 by the time
they finish but in any case right now 16
story mosque oh it's got a swimming pool
it's not a mosque spare me 16 story
mosque at Ground Zero no it's not Ground
Zero it's two blocks away come on have
you ever been there walk walk down the
street turn left there's the World Trade
Center or where the World Trade Center
used to be also part of the landing gear
from one of the 9/11 planes flew into
that building crashed through the roof
fell five stories to the basement the
building that they're going to demolish
to build this mosque this building is
part of the attack site this building is
is Ground Zero and people have made fun
of this idea and said it's about dust or
something nobody's talking about dust if
you talk about dust clouds and where the
dust clouds from 9/11 fell you could go
into
Jersey I'm talking about an actual part
of the attack site this is the most
appropriate place for a mosque of
Triumph and if it is built it will
encourage Islamic Jihad activity which
is bad for
people around the world
it kills people it oppresses people it
denies freedoms it's bad it's not racist
to say so thanks very much